thanks to blinkist for helping support
this episode
hey crazies we've been hearing about
supermassive black holes a lot in the
news lately
we just took a picture of one at the
center of our own galaxy
they aren't kidding when they say these
things are super massive either
the one i just showed you has a mass of
4 million suns
and that's actually on the low end for
supermassive black holes
some of their masses are in the billions
of suns
the problem is
none of them should exist
[Music]
what do you mean they don't exist i i
didn't say they don't exist i said they
shouldn't exist
but more on that later
first we need to understand exactly what
supermassive means
black holes come in two classes based on
their mass
stellar mass black holes are exactly as
they sound they have a mass comparable
to a star
measuring that in solar masses multiples
of the sun's mass they range anywhere
from about three to about 200 solar
masses
then there's a big gap
we don't find black holes again on this
chart until we get into the millions of
solar masses
that's the beginning of what we call
supermassive black holes
they're not just massive
they're super massive
anyway we tend to find these super
massive black holes at the centers of
galaxies our own milky way galaxy has
one weighing in at about 4 million solar
masses we've known it was there for a
while because of what it's doing to the
nearby stars
those stars are also what helped us
calculate its mass
the recent picture we took is only
confirming what we already knew
but don't get the wrong impression
this bad boy might have a mass of 4
million suns but it would fit inside
mercury's orbit
at most it can only fit 17 suns across
its diameter this thing is smaller than
most active giant stars but contains the
mass of millions
and that's just the upper bound on its
mass the fact that it's spinning makes
it even smaller
be careful not to confuse mass with
volume
then again as as far as supermassive
black holes go ours is kind of a runt
we also took a picture of the one at the
center of m87
that one weighs in at about 6.5 billion
solar masses
that's over 1600 times the mass of our
own black hole
and that isn't even the most massive one
we've
found the universe isn't old enough for
any stellar mass black holes to have
become super massive
but again more on that later
first we need to understand how black
holes usually form
inside an active star there's a very
delicate balance at work called
hydrostatic equilibrium the inward
collapse of gravity is held at bay by
the outward radiation pressure from the
core
at the end of a star's life the nuclear
fuel runs out and that radiation
pressure stops
if the star is massive enough the core
collapses into a black hole and the
immense energy release during the
collapse blows the rest away in a
supernova
that's an explosion that can outshine an
entire galaxy
so only the core becomes a black hole
yep how much of the star's mass is that
only about 10 to 15 percent
which limits the mass a black hole can
have when it forms
that outward radiation pressure from a
star's core doesn't just overcome
gravity it also pushes particles out of
the star's surface into space
we call it a stellar wind
the more massive a star is the hotter
its core which means more radiation
pressure which means there are more
particles being emitted if the star's
mass is high enough that stellar wind is
so intense that the mass of the star
noticeably decreases it's called the
eddington limit
if a star tries to form with a higher
mass the mass of that star will decrease
down to that limit we estimate it's
about 130 solar masses and if the core
is only at most 15 percent of that mass
the black hole it eventually makes will
only be about 20 solar masses
wait wait didn't you say that stellar
mass black holes can get up to 200 solar
masses yeah that's where black hole
collisions become important
this 20 solar mass limit is only for the
formation of a stellar mass black hole
but stars often form in binary systems
and sometimes even trinary systems if
both stars in a binary system are in the
upper mass bracket then they're both
going to become black holes and if we
give them enough time they'll emit
gravitational waves and merge with each
other
given even more time those larger merged
black holes can find each other and
merge again
based on our estimates stars have been
around long enough for that process to
reach a maximum of about 200 solar
masses
this estimate is consistent with data
from our gravitational wave
observatories
the vast majority are actually under 100
black holes with higher masses are
outliers
even with mergers though there hasn't
been enough time to make a black hole
larger than 200 solar masses let alone
anything supermassive
but more on that right now
of the stars around today are third
generation stars that means it's the
third time that material has been used
to make a star
first generation stars were certainly
some of the most massive that have ever
lived and they live very short lives but
they still only made stellar mass black
holes when they ended
we're going to need them to start way
bigger and way earlier to reach
supermassiveness that's not even a word
i do what i want
to make a supermassive black hole we
need to start with a star with tens of
thousands of solar masses
and we need that star to exist during a
period of the universe when stars
shouldn't have been possible
the early universe was a very different
place back before stars back before
galaxies the universe was pretty uniform
but it wasn't perfectly uniform
these slight non-uniformities are what
ultimately became super clusters full of
galaxies let's say for the sake of
argument though that something else
formed there first
say the material collapsed so fast in
one particular spot that it skipped over
nuclear fusion and immediately became a
tiny black hole
now if a tiny black hole formed today it
would almost immediately evaporate fast
fast
but back in the early universe it
wouldn't have had a chance it's
surrounded by mostly uniform material
material that would fall in causing the
black hole to grow
this continuous collapse would release a
lot of energy but the surrounding
material has so much gravity that a
balance could be reached it could reach
hydrostatic equilibrium kind of like a
star
it would be a quasi-star though a better
name for it would be black hole star
rather than an outward pressure caused
by nuclear fusion it would be caused by
material falling into a black hole
the core of this quasi-star would be a
black hole what about the eddington
limit it doesn't apply
that limit assumed there was mostly
empty space for particles to escape to
but in the early universe this quasi
star wouldn't be surrounded by empty
space it would have been surrounded by
mostly uniform material only slightly
less dense than the star itself
any particles emitted in a stellar wind
would just get replaced
over time though the surrounding
material would spread out and cool off
the outer layers of the quasi-star would
gradually dissipate or fall into the
black hole
by then the black hole will have grown
to at least a thousand solar masses but
probably more likely in the tens of
thousands
these intermediate mass black holes
could then accumulate material over time
and occasionally find each other and
merge
ultimately becoming the mammoth black
holes we see at the centers of galaxies
today
do we know this for sure well
no do black holes exist absolutely do
supermassive black holes exist
yes
but black holes are very simple objects
they only have a few properties
mass angular momentum and maybe charge
that's it
it doesn't give us much to use plus
these properties are notoriously
difficult to measure
whether directly or indirectly we need
to be able to see orbiting objects or
in-falling material
and even then we're making some minor
assumptions about orientation
for example we know there are black
holes more massive than the one in m87
we just don't know exactly how much more
massive they are
given the age of the universe we're
pretty sure the absolute upper limit is
around 50 billion solar masses but a few
black holes seem to be larger
then again that's probably because we
haven't gotten a good look at them yet
quasi-stars are just our best guess for
their origin based on current physics we
haven't even had confirmed observations
of first generation actual stars let
alone these possible quasi-stars
but these are both things we'll be
looking for with the james webb space
telescope
astrophysics is hard okay we're doing
our best
you know what else is hard
small talk
today's sponsor blinkist can help with
that
i've been in so many situations where
people are talking about some book they
read and i'm just standing there
thinking how do you have time to read
all this stuff
i certainly don't have time for it
luckily blinkist has gone through the
trouble for me at least for non-fiction
books they shorten them into roughly
15-minute synopses called blinks
you can read these synopses yourself or
listen to someone else read them to you
or both whatever you prefer
blinkist has 5 000 titles from 27
different categories for you to choose
from my personal blinkist library
includes science books like cosmos by
carl sagan the big picture by sean
carroll and physics of the impossible by
michio kaku
as someone who's considering hiring
people in a creative field creativity
inc was recently recommended to me
i don't really have time for a whole
book but i was able to listen to the
blink and get the key ideas
if you're interested blinkist has a
special offer for science asylum viewers
you can click the link in the
description below and you'll get a free
7-day trial and 25 off a premium
membership it'll also let blinkists know
you heard about them from me which helps
out the channel
so what do you think of quasi stars let
us know in the comments
thanks for liking and sharing this video
a special thanks goes out to all my
patreon patrons and youtube members for
making all this possible don't forget to
subscribe if you'd like to keep up with
us and until next time remember it's
okay to be a little crazy
i got a bunch of feedback on how to do
thermal camera experiments better and i
really appreciate it i might use some of
the suggestions to make a proper
follow-up video one that's more than
just me playing around with a new toy
also everyone can stop complaining i
have a proper workbench now anyway
thanks for watching